dieu tout le monde s'établit aujourd'hui
on se retrouve pour un test de jeux
vidéo et plus précisément on va
challenge et squeeze un jeu qu'il a fait
le 24 mai dernier pourquoi je fais cette
vidéo pour deux raisons la première je
mets mes lunettes j'ai 30 ans passés
qu'est ce que tu veux la première c'est
parce que j'avais fait cette vidéo mais
vous en avait parlé dans les
commentaires et j'ai trouvé que c'était
une bonne idée
la deuxième c'est que le 24 mai dernier
squeeze était malade dans cette vidéo
est peut-être une force que j'arrive à
marquer des points on va clairement
tester les capacités notre cerveau et
voir si toutes les méthodes dont je
parle pour améliorer ses capacités un
peu cognitive qui est quand même l'un
des premiers buts du mentalisme
permettent de faire un score acceptable
ou pas pour le number memory disent
quelque chose de vrai en général un être
humain retient cette chose cet objet
sept chiffres dans sa vidéo squeeze
avait été très bon puisqu'il était allé
jusqu'au 13e ce qui est vraiment bien il
avait raté le 13e donc c'est à dire que
jusqu'au 12e il avait juste alors
d'accord ça s'affiche et ça nous donc la
3c tranquille 34 ça va et pas besoin de
mener mode etc ni encore d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous dire arrêtez de me
dire que je fais des fautes à
mnémotechnique non ça s'écrit comme je
l'écris mois m
n nemo et pas mes mots t'es c'était quoi
998 imagine je rate au numéro 3 on voit
que c'est vraiment à partir de cette que
ça que ça se corse
on arrive - groupe est en fait 170,43
195 non là ça va aller vite j'ai besoin
de rien cent soixante dix 43 195 en fait
là j'ai utilisé ce qu'on appelle la
boucle phonologique ster je les ai
répétés et ça reste dans ma mémoire
temporaire 494 009 700 pages 0,07 pour
james bond mais je sais que ces neuf
parce que j'avais un oeuf au début mais
du coup on set je le mets après et 7
pouces de égale 9 et après je me -0 6
hyper chelou mais du coup ça va trop
vite pour vous le détail 90 ok là ça va
ça me fait encore des dates et des
dessins en tête 24 février 24 février 5
mars 94 mais 5 0 et 76 avec les herbes
la gelée encore parce qu'il était très
simple nous explique j'ai gagné deux
fois en 98 au football c'était où
c'était à paris et à la fin il ya
soixante personnes qui se sont battues
contre 70 personnes on a dû être obligés
d'appeler 8 fois les pompiers haut quand
on arrive au moment fatidique où squeeze
avaient perdu et c'est là que ça me met
la pression
sachant que lui qui était malade ce
genre là
je pense que je les alors au début je me
suis fait une fête série logique à 25 26
après 920 tout court et après 41 32
c'est bon on a passé squeeze bon on a
passé un squeeze malades dont la base
est quand même alors là je m'arrête là
puisque le but c'est vraiment juste de
se faire le challenge je pars je vais
essayer de faire un à chaque fois mieux
ou moins bien pour le prochain fortes
chances et si vraiment ce genre de
vidéos vous plaît vous me le dites dans
les commentaires vous pouvez aussi mais
je les ped et dans ces cas là je pourrai
l'occasion refaire une vidéo où j'essaie
de d aller jusqu'à temps que je perde y
associe au coup d'après on n'en sait
rien alors le jeu sur le temps de
réaction je suis très mauvais à ça je
suis très mauvais dans les jeux vidéo ou
faut réagir très vite pour ce jeu il
avait fini dans le top 91%
moi je le mets dans le top important
allez c'est parti il ya cinq essais dès
que c'est vers faut cliquer
c'est que c'est beaucoup je sais que
c'est trop aller angotti 314 c'est plus
longue à que j'avais l'impression d'être
plus rapide je gardais la souris dans la
main ont fait que je suis débile de 6%
26 mai comment je peux faire
l'une nul aux fins à mesure il reste
deux essais 258 oui 272 je suis dans le
top 41 % squeeze cher m vous gagnez
cette manche dans ce jeu là il va nous
donner des maux et au fur et à mesure on
va dire si ce mot on l'a déjà vu passer
ou si les nouveaux sthers et les
métadonnées notre cerveau c'est ce qu'il
a déjà vu ou c'est ce qu'il a déjà
entendu par contre j'ai bien regardé
l'écran je me concentre et parce que
c'est pas forcément simple surtout avec
des mots qui ne sont pas en français
dire que j'ai pas connaître le sens de
chaque mois j'ai perdu une vie je n'ai
même pas vu sur quels mots mode power on
et à 69 sur le score qui avait fait
squeeze 70 c'est bon même un petit 71 si
vous voulez - 72 - 73 74 ou 1,75
bref on l'a battue donc on s'arrête là
comme tout à l'heure si vous voulez que
je fasse ce jeu là jusqu'aux antilles
vous me le dirait pour l'instant gelé
battu sur deux manches il m'a battu sur
une manche virtuellement parce que
malheureusement celui-ci met à peut
proposer
donc quatrième et dernier je suis là il
est un petit peu chaud pour moi en tout
cas j'ai pas une très bonne mémoire de
localisation l'udc avait fait plus de
13000 point j'ai des doutes sur ma perf
c'est à dire que si je perds on sera à
égalité c'est nul l'égalité hockey
jusqu'ici tout va bien je suppose que le
damier il va augmenter au fur à mesure
en fait la ou les très forts squeeze
c'est d'arriver à vous parler en même
temps moi j'arrive pas quand je me
concentre je me concentre quoi c'est
compliqué pour moi de causer comme ça en
même temps
en fait vraiment visualiser des formes à
la tetris dans sa tête quoi faut se
créer un dessin mentalement
là ça devient chaud quand même un
principe aussi impute cette ligne je
sais qu'il va y avoir un trou où j'ai
pris cher
j'ai pris super cher plus qu'une vie
celui-là ça va il est simple et après il
y en avait en eau
aussi alors il ya dix sept mille ben
c'est bon 17000 et ben c'est pas assez
pas si mauvaise à 17000 squeeze il avait
fait 13 1945 donc si bon donc ça veut
dire que virtuellement je remporte cette
manche
si on avait joué ensemble l'un contre
l'autre le 24 mai dernier j'aurais
remporté la partie merci à lui de
m'avoir fait découvrir le jeu dans sa
vidéo et du coup si vous vous
connaissiez pas le jeu je vous mets le
lien dans la description ainsi que le
lien vers la chaîne de squeeze parce que
si vous connaissez pas ces vidéos c'est
que vous habitez une autre planète donc
allé voir ce qu'il fait sinon pour les
prochaines dédicaces sachez que de se ré
le 28 à mondeville à côté de cora
cultura 14h30 jusqu'à 16h30 pour
dédicacer le livre si vous savez pas de
quoi parle le livre via un lien de la
description vers la vidéo à d'autres
dédicaces qui se mettront en place à la
rentrée je vous dirai ça le moment venu
maintenant je vous invite à sortir votre
crayon place aux produits non je cache
la marque pour noter quelque part sur
votre main ou voulait que la prochaine
vidéo elle va sortir mercredi à 17h30
ici sur la chaîne on parlera de
mentalisme et de non verbale avec le
regard les directions du regard vous
savez des choses dessus et ben on va en
reparler on va aller plus loin mercredi
prochain comme d'habitude si la vidéo
vous a plu vous savez que vous pouvez
faire quelque chose pour l'envoyer un
peu plus vers le ciel et vous pouvez
également vous abonner à la chaîne et
donc rendez vous mercredi à 17h30 ciao
[Musique]
pas tous